let's talk about one of the holiest
sites in the world
[Music]
that's always in the news we have
another session of violence here right
in front of
such a sensitive religious site isn't it
one of the flash points that led to the
11-day conflict Israel's far-right
national security minister itamar
bengvir has visited the AXA mosque
compound and it's a place that you need
to get your head around if you want to
understand what's going on between the
Israelis and Palestinians
foreign
here's the old city and occupied East
Jerusalem the place where Islam Judaism
and Christianity all intersect there are
several sites here that are holy to all
three including this big compound that
rises above everything else Jews call it
the Temple mount
Muslims call it al-haram al-sharif which
means the noble Sanctuary or the Al-Aqsa
mosque compound or sometimes just
Al-Aqsa now right in the middle of
everything is the Dome of the Rock it's
an Islamic Shrine where Muslims believe
the prophet Muhammad ascended to heaven
here is the Al-Aqsa mosque itself it's
got a huge prayer Hall with space for 5
000 worshipers the Alexa mosque got its
name from a reference uh in the Quran
that refers to a mystical night Journey
that the prophet Muhammad made Rebecca
to El Mezza which means the furthest
mosque and that was generally understood
to be in Jerusalem Jerusalem was the
location of the first direction of
prayer for Muslims and was later
changed to Mecca because of that the
Al-Aqsa mosque compound is the third
holiest site in Islam after Mecca and
Medina in Christianity the site matters
because of its significance in the Old
Testament and because Jesus would have
spent time there and it's also the most
holy site in Judaism it's where two
ancient Jewish temples once stood the
first was destroyed by the Babylonians
the second stood for almost 600 years
until it was destroyed by the Romans in
the first century and according to
Jewish teachings the mount is where a
third Temple should be built when the
Messiah a savior figure is sent by God
now for most of the last 800 years the
compound was controlled by Muslim rulers
and wasn't accessible to non-muslims
traditionally Jewish law actually
forbids Jews from entering or praying
inside the Temple Mount because it's
considered so holy a place of divine
presence
so Jews pray outside the compound at the
Western Wall which is thought to have
been part of the second temple even to
this day the overwhelming majority of
Orthodox rabbis will say you are not
allowed to visit what this means is that
throughout the Millennia the Temple
mount for Jews was a focus of devotion
but there were no particular demands
pending the coming of the Messiah all of
that changed in 1967.
[Music]
that's when Israel seized control of the
Gaza Strip and the West Bank including
East Jerusalem in the Six-Day War
Between the Arabs and Israelis
but when it came to Al-Aqsa the Israelis
stuck with an arrangement that kept
something called the walk-off in charge
it's an Islamic trust that's run by
Jordan Jordan would retain control over
the actual compound itself the Alexa
mosque its custodian ship of its
Administration its upkeep who could
access the site who couldn't access the
site uh you know pram worship and that
whole Arrangement is wrapped up in this
idea known as the status quo it's a
Latin phrase which means the situation
as it is now but in this context the
status quo refers to how things are done
at Al-Aqsa very simple
Muslims pray non-muslims to visit
or stop if I were to try and translate
this into the description of a dynamic
um the holy Esplanade Haram Temple mount
is exclusively a place of worship for
Muslims
that is open to the dignified and
respectful visits of non-muslims
and in coordination with the autonomous
authorities of the work that's the
theory anyway what actually happens in
practice is another thing because
remember Israel occupies East Jerusalem
and has a heavy security presence in the
old city including at the gates of the
Al-Aqsa compound so effectively it's the
Israeli police not the walk-off
officials who ultimately control who
goes in and out although it wasn't
always so explicit
there was a shift in the early 2000s
after the Palestinian Uprising against
the Israeli occupation known as the
second intifada we saw Israel then
controlling not only the vicinity around
the Alaska
but also the unlocks the most compound
itself taking control over security
access and allowing increasing numbers
of Jews to access the site the change in
the Israeli perspective is
we're not your guests we're here a
landlord
and we're going to show you that we're
your landlord and what we're seeing is
Israel increasingly exercising that
control and more and more accusations
that they're breaking the agreed
conventions of the status quo
so there are lots of ways that the
status quo has been violated
restrictions uh on Muslim warship which
is something that the Israeli occupation
imposes quite frequently sometimes age
restrictions usually limiting men of a
certain age from entering the site if
they feel that there may be protests or
or something happening we're all set
seeing more Jewish prayer whether it's
silent but slowly it's becoming much
more of that now
[Music]
there is Jewish prayer I've seen it
daily
uh but beyond that
there is a triumphalism an
ultra-national triangleism which is
perceived as a violation of the sanctity
of the site by Muslim worshipers and
people in the Muslim world the backdrop
to all of this is the growing power of
far-right groups and religious
hardliners in Israel for example there
is the Temple Mount movement that's been
around for decades it brings together a
range of groups who want to overturn the
status quo throughout the years that
Fringe uh became less of a fringe
and during the 1980s and the 1990s began
to go mainstream and today it is not
only not a fringe it is in power so
you've got people like the new national
security minister it's Amar bengaver who
entered the Al-Aqsa compound after only
a few days on the job he says the
arrangements that limit Jewish access
are racist
it's one thing to have a
non-governmental entity or groups of
individuals go but when you have
ministers going up to the site it's it's
very different he was effectively
asserting what he had promised during
his campaign uh during the Electoral
run-up which was Jewish Supremacy and
sovereignty over all of Israel that's
why what Ben Geer did was so provocative
lots of countries condemned it the U.N
security Council called a special
session about it because there's always
the fear of how quickly things can
escalate when it comes to Alexa
[Music]
like in the early 2000s when a visit by
the then opposition leader Ariel Sharon
triggered the second into fada
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone when Israeli forces stormed
Al-Aqsa Moss during Ramadan
it all spiraled and led to an 11-day
Israeli War on Gaza
thank you
our mission is both an explosive but it
is even more a Detonator and with the
climatic conditions are correct what
happens on the mount can make the region
uh erupt in Flames I'll access such a
powerful symbol so what happens there
takes on an even bigger Dimension and
for Palestinians it's become emblematic
of their wider struggle the constant
chipping away of their rights their land
and their identity didn't get to 700 000
Israeli settlers in the occupied
territories overnight it happened house
by house Brick by Brick Road by Road
settlement by settlement and so that's
what's happening with the status quo
it's being eroded bit by bit it is a
slow piecemeal process that the
International Community generally
tolerates the Israeli governments
haven't faced any real costs or
repercussions for those actions and so
it's that impune D that allows them to
kind of keep pushing the envelope
further each time
check out our recent episode on what's
happening in Iran and make sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel to get
notified the next time there's a new
episode of start here
[Music]